I'm told you got hurt recently I hope  you're okay what happened well I had to  take a little time off modeling I uh I  wrecked my back you wrecked your I  wrecked my back you ever hurt your back  you injured your back  yeah pretty bad would happen well kind  of worried people are gonna laugh but I  was had the leaf blower gone you had to  leap well going huh full blast huh and  I'm an obsessive-compulsive  mmm-hmm you know I get in the yard I got  to get every damn leaf in the yard yeah  so I got this sucker cranked all the way  to ten I'm blowing every damn leave and  fell out of the tree  why well why do I ask you here why their  lies they're all lies  look I could be on the catwalk in Perry  right yeah sure yeah  you